faute au climat et à l'altitude les
arbres ne deviennent pas très grands sur
l'île de la
Réunion du coup le sous-bois ne présente
pas ou peu d'espace disponible à la
profusion
d'espèces
toutefois certaines ont su tirer parti
de l'ombre et de l'humidité procurée par
les
arbres le bois de raisin fait partie de
celle-ci deux espèces se distinguent sur
l'île mais toutes deux se ressemble et
les distinctions sont des préoccupations
pileuses propres au botanistes le bois
de raisin se développe en boule assez
compact pouvant atteindre 5 m de haut
parfois
plus les feuilles relativement grandes
se terminent en pointe les nervures
presque parallèles sont très marquées et
dessinent remarquablement le dos des
feuilles pendant la période de floraison
le bois de raisin ne peut pas passer
inaperçu il se par de nombreuses grappes
de fleurs blanc crème qui retombe
délicatement
les insectes et autres papillons de jour
visitent rapidement les fleurs qui
s'ouvrent de façon éphémère les unes
après les autres
elles ne se font presque pas remarquer
tellement les grappes elles-mêmes
offrent un spectacle
ravissant et pourtant si petite si fine
si si
délicate faut-il que la plante sorte ce
grand jeu afin de guider les insectes
jusque-
là et ce n'est pas fini les grappes de
fleurs vont laisser la place à des
grappes de raisin quelle ressemblance
mais ce sont bien des fruits de bois de
raisin voilà encore l'explication du nom
donné à la plante car ce n'est pas à
cause de son goût je peux vous l'assurer
les fruits Sagan serrés les uns à côté
des autres formant une grappe conique
qui pend alourdi par son propre poids
vert d'abord ils prennent une couleur
bleue plus ou moins foncée en mûissant
seul les petits poils et les reste des
calices dressés sur les fruits révèl la
supercherie en tout cas les oiseaux ne
font pas la fine bouche et raisin ou pas
il passe tellement vite dès que les
grains sont à bonne maturité qu'on a du
mal à les rem
le bois de raisin fait partie de ces
quelques espèces qui ont élu domicile
dans les sous-bois entre l'ombre et le
soleil qui illumine ses braquetés au gré
du
vent